[Music]
my life directed by Nicolas Winding
revin is a documentary directed by his
wife about the filmmaking process the
stresses and the difficulties that that
director underwent when he made only God
forgives
I don't usually focus on documentaries
on my channel but this was one that I
have received a lot of requests for and
I wanted to do that for you guys because
I do have an interest in the filmmaking
process obviously I've been a short
filmmaker ever since I was a teenager
I'm always riding on the side I'm always
doing short films on the side with
friends and so I'm always very
interested to see how another filmmaker
approaches making a movie how it affects
him personally
the emotion that he has behind the
scenes as well as when he's on the set
and I was looking forward to this
documentary because I have been
following his career ever since drive
exploded I watched his previous films
and I've watched all of his films since
although only God forgives was not as
good as drive and had a lot of elements
to it that bother me that weren't quite
right there were still beautiful aspects
of that film and so I was very curious
to see the behind the scenes look and
the best aspects of this documentary are
by far the parts where it shows him
actually on set discussing how he films
a scene talking about storyboards
showing his notecards you could just see
him and Ryan Gosling working together
trying to get the emotion correct I love
that aspect of this movie because I'm
constantly interested in filmmaking and
I love seeing how artists get together
and work and how they try to construct a
scene and all the various difficulties
that come along with that because I can
tell you personally ever since I was a
teenager and I picked up a camera and
said I'd like to try to make some movies
it's hard it's really hard to do the
best movies are the ones where people
look and say well I can do that but
that's just because people who are
really good at what they do make it look
easy and those are the aspects of this
documentary that I really liked and then
I wanted to see unfortunately there's a
lot more stuff in this documentary that
I didn't want to see like his family
life him piling around with his
daughters this is directed by his wife
and there's a marital strife going on as
well that's sort of infused in there the
depression that he suffered while making
this movie these are things that I'm not
terribly wanting to see and I've been
called a fanboy for various directors
but the simple fact of the matter is I
love filmmaking and I'm always
interested in a direct
that I appreciate and how he makes a
film but I don't want to know what's
going on in his home I'm not the guy who
watches reality TV I don't need to see
keeping up with the reference that's not
my idea of a good time I'm not one of
those guys that likes to intrude on
other people's privacy like I'm a big
Steven Spielberg fan I don't want to
know at him and his family do for dinner
I just want to see his next film and you
know what I mean and if the scenes
involving Ruffins family life were more
about filmmaking and less about tarot
card readings about whether or not they
should get a divorce
I would have enjoyed this documentary a
lot more the other issue is that has
less than an hour long it's barely even
feature-length this should have been a
special feature on the only guy for
gifts blu-ray it would have definitely
gotten deep into the difficulties that
ref and faced while making this movie in
the documentaries best scene he has an
outburst about the fact that he's just
not feeling like it's working the best
parts of this documentary are when he as
a director starts to realize that the
film isn't exactly what he wanted it to
be when he reads some of the critics
reviews those are my favorite parts of
this documentary its short length and
the fact that nothing really happens of
extreme merit other than the fact that
it was a very stressful experience to
make this movie which is pretty much the
same for every director out there make
this a documentary that I can't really
recommend I am a fan of Ruffins work I
liked seeing the behind the scenes but
the fact that it's like 54 minutes long
that there's all this extra family
baggage scenes that just feel like they
put it in there to kind of lengthen it
beyond a making-of blu-ray featurette I
can't recommend you guys spending your
hard-earned money on something that
really should have just been on the
blu-ray I'm gonna give my life directed
by Nicolas Winding roughen a C+ a
documentary that I will recommend
however is one I saw earlier this year
in my art house theater near by me
called the kingdom of dreams and madness
it is about Studio Ghibli Hayao Miyazaki
East out Takahata their relationship the
hardships they face while they make
animation which by the way considerably
harder than you may think
that is definitely a documentary about
filmmaking that you guys should check
out Kingdom of Dreams and madness guys
thank you so much as always for watching
if you did see this doc let me know what
you thought of it below and of course
thank you so much as always for watching
guys
greatly appreciate it and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes
[Music]